you have the same management shot to
100k management as a lot of other dope
artists but uh no notably uh mellie yeah
um we actually did the
the last y w melee interview before he
turned himself in
um
what what would you ever have a
relationship with him or yeah see me and
mele
like
i think it was about like 2015 that's
when i went to my program so i'm saying
i went to my program uh mellie went to a
program too but he was in there with
people from the old stuff and they'd be
like oh mellie asks about you really
asked about you whatever around that
time in both of us was like
rapping
just not starting to get out buzz like
around the same time
but boom yeah mellie was asking about me
you know i've never seen millie before
so you guys never actually physically
met nah
but you guys were both locked up at the
same time it was locked up at the same
time okay boom got out separate places
though
yeah he got out then i got out shortly
after but it was like boom
bro was like he was grinding though i'm
when i was in the program i was watching
him
yeah i got out i'm watching him
i'm like damn that way taking off he's
going crazy
but you know man he gonna always show
love he's i'm saying so many milly uh
[ __ ] around he put my name in the song
but i ain't i ain't noticed i ain't
noticed i got out i've been saying
really i'm like huh go to it i'm like
yeah that's real but we never seen each
other we're under the same management or
not i don't talk to me before we got a
song
you guys have chopped it up like of
course yeah got like um two songs what
was the line that he dropped your name
in he says uh switcheroo just like hot
boy
my first song i ever released cops were
true that [ __ ] went crazy
that [ __ ] went crazy
that was like my first song i released
though